hey let's go press my name Oh Oh my name
[Music]
today we're gonna play Lego world's
it's like Minecraft and you bros always
say I wish you would play Minecraft but
I always say I'm too hipster for that
[ __ ]
so we're gonna play Lego world's oh wait
this is not how it starts give me one
second one second all right this is how
it starts
the [ __ ] is that oh the sherry blossoms
are blossoming early this year but the
[ __ ] is this okay someone is getting
milk oh god he just died so it's
basically Lego but minecraft I love Lego
I won't let go so much I don't care what
the haters say Lego all day okay I am
just placing drop-kicked Lego blocks
randomly but cuz that's my life I also
notice that if you punch flowers in this
game you get coins a little disappointed
that doesn't translate into real life
that's just why we have video games
really oh god what am i doing
what am i doing what is going on
[Music]
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what is happening
what is this what the [ __ ] is it a large
volcanic spike of course not flower
punch it stupid flower so I can punish
skeletons punch those flowers baby punch
that mushroom get rekt mushroom it's
such a horse can't don't be sad you that
horse climbing a [ __ ] tree I saw you
what are you doing horse let me ride you
[ __ ] amazing yeah to the sunset god
damnit I thought I could drown your
horse you win this round horse you win
this round
ah communis bang son and punch the [ __ ]
out of you or looking at my horse you
[ __ ] where are you going
got punch you
get rekt [ __ ] oh my god that's brutal
his head where's your weight aunt said
instead of treasure chest I remember
these as a kid oh my god yes I'm gonna
buy all the [ __ ]
I mean I'm gonna don't tell myself
please okay
[ __ ] is that an eagle sponsor eagle what
are you doing here can i sponsor eagle
fly sponsor eagle amazing Wow Wow
whoa can I go up into the clouds no oh
the clouds leggo thank you sponsor eagle
there we can finally be together alone
sponsor Iike you know I love you right
kiss me don't dodge my kisses sponsor
eagle it's almost like you don't want to
kiss me sponsor eagle where are you
going sponsor sponsor eagle I thought
you loved me we have to land on him
nevermind alright [ __ ] it let's let's
start building some some [ __ ] race whoa
is that long or what happens if we go
inside the lava
I don't know why I asked these questions
all right well it's time to start
building we're gonna start by building a
big nice fat juicy [ __ ] surprisingly I
never did this as a kid this obsession
with penis came at a lot later age let
it grow let it grow can't stop that
penis any mo let it grow let it grow
think that's enough alright alright
alright this absolute stunning look how
the light reflects on that giant penis
it's a bit thin like a straw but it's
all thought part of the plan don't you
worry alright well that's close enough
alright we built our first thing it
looks like we have our first fan right
there yeah there do you did you enjoy it
he enjoys it he loves it [ __ ] you it's
mine so many people was to get my tower
[ __ ] off
it's my tower and playing the bongo
[ __ ] how do I get rid of this
[ __ ] ready my pick Becky what is she
doing to you my my piggy piggy joins the
party yeah that's right
in your face huh in your face [ __ ] in
your face suck it suck his face next up
is to fill our house I'm gonna build you
like a house the house of fabulous yes
[Music]
only I knew how to make like a straight
line maybe [ __ ] fabulous [ __ ] you
then alright we got we got our base I'm
all about that looks fabulous
holy [ __ ]
I just built I just built a [ __ ]
window look at that look at it
[ __ ] Leonardo da Vinci that [ __ ] the
House of fab has like a [ __ ] entrance
and [ __ ] now horses love it I got a
[ __ ] window it's [ __ ] that I can
climb if I want to but I'm getting a
little a little tired of building so
we're gonna go and continue this why did
I say Tina Turner you're riding a sheep
[ __ ] you it's my sheep
I'm the ruler of the sheep's of course
of course
ah the dick tower looks great and tall
today when you bounce nicely enough look
at him whoo
yeah what's up that's what I'm talking
about
dude is that a [ __ ] race car are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] my ass out right now
why am I going reversed why the [ __ ] did
I go what is happening help
[Music]
I mean right or left oh I never thought
I'd see my own wife and food and family
again okay let's keep drinking how are
we gonna dig ourselves out of this mess
Oh drilling machine no all right all
right all right Kendall you waited for
me all right all right all right
oh the pyramids camos now Gandalf don't
be jealous
I always wanted to ride a camel oh man I
remember the camels from when I was a
kid
holy [ __ ] the camels are [ __ ] beasts
missing me Oh Mike I don't think he
likes it
keep dancing keep dancing keep dancing
never stop dancing polar [ __ ] [ __ ]
polar bears [ __ ] please man oh man I
was sorry camel Eko your money miss
friendly I see do you wanna ride an
iceberg an airplane and this game makes
me feel like a kid I love it helicopter
I'll go with air place
oh my god oh it's a wild wild west look
at that face you look like my next
mistake let's let's finish this episode
off by flying into the lava because that
worked out so well last time yes just
what I wanted in life sweet death
alright breasts kinda have to in that
episode there had a lot of fun playing
with us today leave a like if you want
to do that and I'll see you